Congresswoman Katie Porter has really become
very, very good at humiliating people who
seem to think she's clueless, people who go
in to testify before Congress and apparently
think that they're going to be able to get
one over on her when they are not, because
she's not only extremely knowledgeable on
all issues, financial and business, but extraordinarily
well prepared.
And there was a subcommittee hearing yesterday
called Modernizing Energy Development Laws
for the benefit of taxpayers, communities
in the environment.
It's a mouthful.
One of the people who was testifying was Mark
Murphy, the president of the Strato Production
Company in Roswell, New Mexico.
This is an oil and gas company.
It's not a huge company.
They have 16 employees and generate, according
to a report, about two and a half million
dollars in sales.
So it's not a massive company, but not particularly
relevant today.
And in an exchange with Katie Porter, Murphy
tries to claim there's no special tax rules
for oil and gas.
If we have expenses, we get to deduct expenses
like any other business, trying to suggest
there aren't special rules that apply to oil
and gas that don't apply to a mom and pop
hardware store or a taco stand or whatever
the case may be.
It's not true.
And Katie Porter knew it and she wasn't going
to let it slip.
Take a look.
They're estimated to be between 60 to 90 percent
of the costs of drilling.
How much of those intangible drilling costs
do you go to the doctor right away from your
taxes?
We get to deduct all of those just like any
other business.
We do not.
How much do you think I took?
The tax seems to be a misconception out there
that you're operating from, that somehow the
oil and gas industry benefits from some special
sort of tax structure.
We don't we actually we actually have an industry
group of.
I will follow up with you, Mr. Murphy, but
you do benefit from special rules.
There's a special tax law for intangible drilling
costs that does not apply to other kinds of
expenses that businesses have.
You get to deduct 70 percent of your costs
immediately and other businesses have to amortize
their expenses over their entire profits.
We also Prisco, please don't patronize me
by telling me of the oil and gas industry
doesn't have any special tax provisions, because
if you would like that to be the rule, I would
be happy to help Congress deliver.
I yield back.
So it actually goes way beyond just this.
The truth is that there are many tax benefits
available for oil and gas investors that aren't
available elsewhere in the tax code for other
types of businesses.
And some of them are sort of relatively not
so much esoteric, but because they only apply
to to a very narrow scope of business, a lot
of people aren't aware of them.
The two largest subsidies for oil and gas
are something called excess of percentage
over cost depletion and the expensing of exploration
and development costs.
These add up to billions in subsidies for
companies like Mark Murphys.
And when we talk about excessive percentage
over cost depletion, what this allows producers
a harvester's of oil and gas to do is deduct
a fixed percentage of gross revenue as a capital
expense each year, regardless of whether they
actually had that capital expense or not.
So when you see the way that you would you
would typically deduct costs is you deduct
real costs.
You have a million dollars in revenue and
one hundred thousand dollars in costs, and
you deduct one hundred thousand dollars in
real costs.
This special rule for oil and gas allows producers
like Mark Murphy's Company to deduct 15 percent
of gross revenue for what's called resource
depletion, regardless of whether they actually
incurred that as an amount of cost.
You just chop 15 percent right off the top.
You made 10 million.
You get to deduct one point five million,
15 percent because you are depleting your
source of oil and gas.
You get a benefit.
From the very depletion of a resource which
you are executing, what that is a specific
benefit for oil and gas, intangible drilling
costs, which include everything but actual
drilling equipment.
So when you when you do drilling, there's
labor, there's chemicals, there's grease,
there's all sorts of other stuff that are
considered intangible.
These expenses normally are 60 to 80 percent
of the total cost of drilling a well, and
they are 100 percent deductible in the year
incurred.
So if it costs three hundred thousand dollars
to drill a well and we say well of that, three
hundred thousand seventy five percent is intangible.
The investor gets a deduction right away of
the full amount.
Even if you don't produce oil, even if you
don't strike oil, as long as you started to
operate that facility by the 31st of March
of the following year, you get to deduct all
this stuff regardless of what's actually happening.
Most businesses don't get to do that.
Oil and gas also get accelerated depreciation
of infrastructure and they also get an exemption
on alternative minimum tax.
And I know we're getting sort of like wonky.
And here there's something called alternative
minimum tax.
The point of alternative minimum tax is to
avoid people from being able to deduct all
the way down to owing nothing.
So at higher incomes, imagine you make five
million dollars you might be able to by combining
accelerated depreciation, intangible deductions,
all this different stuff, you might be able
to say, hey, you know what?
I have an adjusted income of only a million
dollars, even though there was a five million
dollars that came in, I've got all these different
deductions, I get down to a million dollars.
The point of alternative minimum tax is to
say you can't deduct yourself below a certain
level of taxable income.
The tax law specifically exempts those intangible
drilling costs from alternative minimum tax.
So regardless of your amte, you can always
continue to deduct out those intangible drilling
costs.
That's a gift to oil and gas.
So nice job by Katie Porter pointing out that
there are special exceptions made for oil
and gas that don't apply to other businesses.
And I could go on with even more of these.
There are actually a ton of them.
And the whole point, the oil and gas industry
doesn't want you to know about this, because
if you did, you might be outraged, as you
should be